there is mr. Mikey Mikey Taylor so for
those of you guys who don't know Mikey
is a pro skateboarder former pro
skateboarder had a huge career and has
successfully transitioned to
entrepreneur and investor and we're
gonna pick his brain for a couple
minutes here while he pulled over thanks
for making the time in what I wanted to
talk about is living your story what I
loved about your your mindset your
attitude is you just go for things and I
think so many entrepreneurs they get in
their own head they just get in their
own way they overthink things they have
a thousand things on their bucket list
to do and from what I've seen of your
content and your mindset in your
interviews it's like you just you get an
idea you get into a conversation
somebody comes up with something and you
just do it yeah yeah you know what's
funny man my parents always told me I
could do whatever I want but my mom was
actually really fear-based
so for us growing up everything was like
don't do this you could get hurt it was
like this if you step in the street
you're getting in a car accident kind of
way of thinking right and and it drove
me crazy I I I remember being a kid
hating that feeling of not wanting to do
something because of being scared to do
it but that is my natural feeling I
think just because my parents so I did
everything I could to fight it and just
learn that like if I feel fear that
means it's time to push forward and my
worst fear is not doing something
because of I think worrying about if I'm
gonna pull it or not so I just have
force myself man I just don't want to
like think about if I would have made it
you know what's the conversation you
have with yourself is okay we should
start a beer company or we should start
out whatever company and then the fear
starts setting means like well Who am I
to be a real estate investor Who am I to
be a beer manufacturer what do you tell
yourself to then do it yeah so so for me
if there's always a point in the journey
where I start getting scared right and
it's not at the idea I get to the idea
I'm like let's do this it's once I you
know I get all the information when we
start working on it and I get to a point
where there's no turning back it's like
right before then I always get scared
and I always start questioning myself
and worrying about it and I just know
that that's the
point for me that I have to move forward
it's it's it's kind of my okay this is
good these all signs are leading towards
you're doing it the right way because
I'm getting scare at the moment where I
actually need the push and it always
happens at the same point for whatever
reason it's about a year in for me from
idea I don't know why it just always
works out that way
well this what's interesting at the
point where most people are now gonna
back away you force yourself to push
forward like how do you trigger that so
that you always know to jump in like
this is the right thing for me to do so
I think it started with so for
skateboarding right yeah there's a big
part of what we do that is incredibly
scary and and you know I grew up skating
handrails and I was terrified to do them
just all my friends did them and I
wanted to you know be as good as my
friends and you learn to like trick
yourself to get your body to go off the
stairs right everything's telling you
stop and you learn that like this like
kind of like trick or like mind trick
that you can do it and and you learn how
to push through it and I just kind of
took that and related it into I think my
whole life now are you using this to do
outreach into new communities and meet
new people like we met because you you
just randomly DM me and said hey I think
your content is rad
yeah like awesome and then I dive into
your world a little bit more is that
part of your plan like hey there's
somebody who I want to know so I'm just
gonna be end them and see what's up so
this is new for me actually I went
through the algorithm change right yeah
and Instagram was very easy for me to
build my following for the first five
years or so and when first algorithm hit
I went what the hell is going on why
aren't I getting views why aren't right
and it started selfishly me trying to
figure out how to solve it and you know
leading in this okay I need to engage I
need to like reach people and through
the selfish idea of me trying to get my
content to you know get out to more
people it almost brought me back to why
they even created Instagram and it was
for connecting and I felt like I had
missed five years of what I was doing on
Instagram that like I could have used to
like really reaching people that I don't
have access to and once I hit that
realization it became this like holy the
world is at my fingertips right even
with 500,000 followers I
realize what I could do with this thing
until you know needing people like this
last year I've met so many people that I
never would have and it wasn't like a
fear of reaching out it was just I
wasn't even seeing what this thing could
actually do you know so is that now part
of your schedule a part of your routine
somehow I got to reach one new person a
week you know it's not in my routine
actually it it more is just like I go
through the rabbit hole of seeing
something and enjoying it and just now I
think it's just came normal for me to
make the introduction and try to kind of
you know learn from people meet people
and really just start relationships know
every week one new person different
field yeah so think about your early
career I know a little bit I mean your
mom said don't be a skateboarder you're
never gonna make it as a pro like and I
guess at that time you know it was it
was a different market - in terms of a
pro skateboard and make a career off of
it yeah
you were the worst in your in your peer
group or at least weren't weren't the
best yeah for people who are starting
anything with a skateboarding or
anything else where where they don't
have the support of their friends their
family and people around them saying
that's a stupid idea and when they start
doing it they're not even the best in
their peer group and it's just your
sheer perseverance and will and and
dedication that make up for a lack of
early talent what advice to give
somebody who's faced in those same
situations nobody supported me I suck
and hurt my friends why keep going you
know what when it was happening for
whatever reason I just wanted it so bad
that I wanted to push through it and
kind of having gone through it I've just
learned that like this self limiting
belief that a lot of people have whether
it's your parents telling it to you kind
of bad experience is the one thing that
will separate you from being who you
want it actually isn't a talent base at
all and I feel like I'm a living example
that were skateboarder in my group as
far as like the skateboarding industry I
was one of the largest pros and I think
one of the lowest talented ones right I
didn't graduate graduated high school
and ever
went to college everything was like in
my eyes worked for and and I've always
just believed that if you want something
you can go out and get it you just have
to work through it and it's always
worked for me and I'll tell you I am
nothing special
I still struggle like everyone else I've
insecurities like everyone else I'm just
a believer if you can work hard enough
and and basically be resilient enough to
achieve what you're setting out to do it
seems to me as well that you're you're
very open to new experiences you want to
say yes to people you want to dive in
and try things like you you got into
skateboarding cuz a friend of yours got
into it and even though he dropped out
you still wanted to keep going yeah just
that mindset of like try anything once
and see what happens yeah you know what
I I don't like saying no III recognize
that there are times where you you have
to but I try to look at everything as I
want to do it I just feel like just
having a more positive a kind of outlook
on life and and it happened I had a full
life to change I actually found myself
the first 10 years of me skating I had
become really negative and was
complaining about everything and kind of
had this moment where like I was just
kind of fed up with it and ever since
that point of like really making the
decision to change myself really my
whole world changed it just became so
much more enjoyable for me new
opportunities happen I started meeting
new people is kind of it's crazy to
think that the way you look at the ones
around you can really decide really how
successful your life is as a whole so
how do you think other people can make
that switch if they're thinking negative
thoughts if ever around that was
negative how do you how do you break
free from that cycle so I think that's a
handful things the first thing I did was
I started working on changing myself and
it really started as a game for me like
I tried to do this thing where like if
something bad happened I had to find
some type of positive in it even if
there was like nothing and it was a full
reach I really would just grab to have
something right and just every bad I
tried to see the good until the point
where like you almost don't even see the
bad anymore you just have to like really
start making that a priority I started
writing down all my goals every morning
I started writing down who
wanted to be which really helped keep
that on my mind every day and I also
separated myself from people that I felt
weren't adding to bettering the whole
group hmm so as someone who loves saying
yes how do you do that and shut up
people who are negative uh you know what
that that was really hard for me in the
beginning actually I I cuz I got to a
point now we're like even though people
are being negative I want to be more of
an example instead of blocking them out
but at that point I wasn't in this place
right I had two completely separate
myself which is really hard because I
had some friends that were like we were
close friends right and I think that was
the hardest thing for me to was kind of
create distance and try to bring in a
new circle around me and then now I just
have got to the point where like if
somebody's negative I could hear it and
it's not affecting me I just try to help
them through it now but that was through
time that was a ten-year battle to get
to that point got it and that that idea
the first one you said about I always
try to find a bit of positivity in the
negative are there some situations or
examples you can share around that so
about two years ago I lost my sponsor
for skating and I had I had a two year
deal left with them right they found a
clause on basically getting out of my
contract early and overnight I had no
income coming in right which I think you
know I've been a pro 15 years I had two
years left on my deal there would be a
lot to complain about for me in that
instance three months prior to that I
had surgery so I was sitting on the
couch when all this happened my life
really was bad in the sense right and I
just looked at it like okay this could
be the thing that that transforms my
life for the better right I don't like
that my career's over maybe I could use
this to try and reach people in a new
way maybe this is gonna force me to
start looking at a new opportunity for
myself and just was trying to find any
good out of it the company's struggling
they need to go down a different you
know and it did that actually that
instance was the hardest thing I've ever
dealt with my entire life and now being
on the other end of it it's it's by far
the most impacting
situation that I've ever gone through
that has led to the most growth in my
life well it's easy to see how that
could spiral negativity in in a in a
fast way right like you're injured you
lost your deal you thought you'd have
two more this is how you need money for
the past X years your you know the
career of a skateboarder an entrepreneur
can be an entrepreneur forever but as a
skateboarder
you can't go forever no totally and I
think even like the the whole like my
whole world of being a pro skateboarder
right I had found something I loved I
enjoyed every single second of my life
but I had a career that I wasn't gonna
be able to continue to do right and even
through like me getting older I think
there was a point where I could have
complained and become bitter of like
look I'm thirty sponsors don't want to
pay me anymore I think I could add a
totally negative outlook on what my true
passion of skating was and I just
decided that I could now showcase how
you get through a career of enjoying
what it is and then having an afterlife
after that and just try to like find
positivity from it and my life and
enjoyment of life has continued to climb
even through this transition out of
skateboarding which I don't think could
have happened if I looked at it in a
negative way right is there anything you
do on a daily basis that helps you
maintain the positivity yeah so a big
thing for me was like starting a morning
routine and meant to be completely
honest to you when I first started I
thought it was kind of a crock right and
and but I decided to do it right and my
morning routine I started waking up at
5:30 my kids get up at 7:00 so I needed
about an hour and a half before of just
kind of knee time I start with a
devotional it's about thirty minutes and
then I write down five things I'm
thankful for five five kind of
affirmations about myself I write a
paragraph of the ideal person I want to
be and then I have five kind of business
focused goals and then from there I do
yoga for about 30 minutes and I
alternate one day yoga the next day is
working out or running and then I wake
up the kids and for what I found is by
having that time every day to be
thankful has really let me
I think enjoy the blessings around me to
have the time of like myself positive
thinking it just sets my day up to where
I think I'm just enough I'm a better
person going through it right this is
everyday I do it every day yeah and the
devotional is that prayer is that thanks
to God what do you do what's a
devotional so I I've never read the
Bible and okay really really wanted to
so I got an app where you could read the
Bible in a year okay so it's like
basically and the Bible could be kind of
hard to read write or understand so it's
basically five verses and then a full
like kind of devotional or breakdown of
what that message is and how it relates
into life and I started doing that and
I'm at 365 more days until okay what's
gonna happen after I gotta pick a new
thing I don't know yeah well cuz the
first thing is so important like you get
out of bed and you do this thing and
that's the routine yeah yeah so I'll
keep everything I'm just gonna change
the first 30 minutes right it will be
it'll be something focused on learning
for me whether it's a new book and then
basically when I write down every day
the yoga that'll all stay the same I
just need a new 30 minutes of uh I'd say
bettering or
self learning cool I love it out well
I'm curious to figure out what you do
what the next thing is you're gonna post
it to Instagram this talk was switching
careers so some of the some of the I
guess mindset and discipline from
skating carries over to investing in
entrepreneurship but but the skills that
you learn of how to do different tricks
and like you're basically starting over
yeah yeah and you've had success in
doing that and I'm wondering a lot of
people feel like when they're 30 it's
too late to reinvent themselves it's too
late to jump to a totally different
industry it's too late to go follow that
thing because I went to school for this
and I've learned these skills and you
basically flush you down the toilet and
said okay it's over and now I'm gonna go
off and do this and learn the new skills
what advice you have for somebody who's
in that spot where they're afraid to
transition okay so I would say that I
think
a testament to that it could be done
right it I didn't just have a career
that no one knew what I was doing and
then switched I built mice
I built a name for myself a full
following career that was very visible
and then had to turn it and and I'm not
gonna lie to you it's difficult it's not
easy to do but but the things that you
don't think of or what's difficult it's
the motional side that's difficult not
the not the actual learning a new craft
right for me to like you know when it
was switching into you know the first
business and then moving into real
estate investing and then starting a
company based on real estate investing
that was actually pretty easy to learn
it was a motion letting go of who I was
over here and and accepting who I was
here and kind of having to worry about
bringing a fan base with you was was not
the hardest part for me but to tell you
the truth man I think it's all the same
actually it's different things that I'm
selling or it's maybe different terms or
how the model works but what what made
me successful in skating I believe those
same skill sets will make me and have
made me successful in entrepreneurship
or real estate it's just giving yourself
time to learn learn how you can apply
these skills from here to here now
you've been interested in investing
almost from the get where you started
making money and it wasn't about going
and buying fancy jackets and cars and
all this stuff it's like I want to I
want to put it I want to invest it I
want to make passive income yeah do you
think if you had shared some of that
while you were skating they would have
helped or made a difference yes a
hundred percent I think absolutely would
unfortunately for me I was too young and
too insecure about myself to put myself
out there in that way and and what I
mean by that is skating and the skate
industry is incredibly negative right
like they don't want anyone to be
successful you don't plan to be
successful you don't want to win it's a
very like raw like core industry right
and so I think when I was young I was so
worried about not being accepted and not
wanting to tell people that I actually
did desire to be successful that I was
planning for my future that I
kept it quiet and and actually I think
of negative to this but I had almost
lived to life's right like when I was
with skaters I talked and acted a
certain way and everything behind closed
doors it was like I was a totally
different person I was just too scared
to put myself out there like that and
and it just for me man I wish it wasn't
the case it just took me time to get
older and more comfortable with myself
to just go you know what this is who I
am
take it or leave it right and and so for
anybody I wish I actually if I could you
know hindsight 20/20 I would have
started talking right that's the twenty
years old you know and that's when you
started investing eighteen or twenty
somewhere in that wrench the first time
I invested I was I was about to be
twenty-one twenty-two twenty right yeah
I think about it because so many people
now who are trying to build their
Instagram brand whether they're artists
or they're singers or they're their
borders skateboarders or surfers or
whatever and they are having an image
that they're trying to portray but then
there's somebody else behind the scenes
is that your advice to them now gosh my
advice would be be completely authentic
and showcase that on your brand if you
build a brand that's not about you
you're gonna get to a point where it's
gonna implode either you or the brand
right so I think the best thing is just
put yourself out there the way you want
to be represented and don't worry so
much about what people think of that
right so how do you do that when you
want to be seen as a person on the fancy
Jets and you want it you want to be seen
and it helps you sell your product or
whatever you're right but it's not
actually you you know what I might be
the wrong person to talk about that
because personally I think it's wack
right like yeah there's a part of that
that feels fake to me and I I do
struggle with a lot of the people that
you see on Instagram right now granted I
understand they're selling a brand I
understand that they're using that to
sell product but but now with social
media and how there's a face to that
brand it gets blurry and and it's just
for me it's hard to watch now if you
totally honest with you I'd rather see
somebody like out there actually
grinding and getting it just this is
what I'm doing dog I'm in front of this
place trying to sell this thing on my
trunk
rather than
you know rent the hour to shoot
portraits at a jet and kind of showcase
your life one way is not me you know
so for dealing with with backlash for
dealing with haters and negativity
I'm sure you get it now like Mikey like
go back to skateboarding Mikey like what
are you doing talking about real estate
man like show me a show me a trick I
don't like I don't like what you're
doing now man like what happened how do
you deal with that backlash or
negativity that I'm sure comes your way
I know there's a lot of love but no so I
it's funny I did something ten minutes
before we got on this call about that
exact topic right okay it's it's it's
not easy right like I I am now to the
point where I am completely putting out
a new message not skate trick here
lifehere skate you know and and I get
those comments a lot and I do get people
go back to the old you and I think kids
don't like look at 14 years old I didn't
understand how this worked either right
I didn't understand that the control is
not in the athlete the control is in the
sponsor paying the athlete to continue
right I just didn't understand how it
works so when pros stepped away I was
like why is he done he doesn't like
skating anymore that's whack right I
didn't understand that there's a
different mechanic to the whole industry
so yeah it's just I think for me I put
myself in a kid's position of just not
understanding how it works and really
like look this is this is what I want to
put out and and I have enough around me
and Allah enough good people my wife
father there's priorities of what I'm
trying to accomplish and it's just not
trying to please anyone anymore it's
trying to help the people that are gonna
I guess receive what I'm putting out you
know negative that is that is it gets
easier through time but the first time I
experienced that was almost quit skating
because of it it's it's a mmm I think
that's a tough thing for anyone to deal
with and you know I want to recognize
you for helping be a shield for others
like by you admitting that it's hard and
impacts you but I'm still gonna go
forward and do it and here's how I
handle it and now gets permission other
people like it's okay to feel bad when
you get a negative comment
going absolutely and I think like to
what I do to actually help that a lot of
times when people say something negative
you need to remember that that person is
going through a certain experience and
they're in that life and usually it's
actually not directed towards you right
so I try to not get you know not take it
personal try to recognize that people
struggle people have hard situations and
just look I hope you get through
whatever you're going through I'm not
gonna take a personal I'm gonna keep
doing this and hopefully you know you
make it through that situation and we
all can kind of get through this
together yeah if the highlight of
somebody's day is going to - Mikey
Taylor's Instagram and leaving some hate
like that person's life is pretty yeah I
mean in the Pittsburgh memory totally
and I think like I just try to like
recognize that like people struggle
right there's days where I don't I'm not
good - there's days where I see you do
you don't a jet and I want to comment
right and I just try to recognize it
like we're all imperfect trying to be
our best you know cool I know where
we're cutting down on time I want to
quickly touch on what you're doing now
commune capital tell us about it what is
what you're doing who you're helping
yeah so when I went through this this
losing my sponsors I I was in a position
where like I was going through a very
emotional time but I had planned for the
financial side so tough that that I
didn't have to go find a job right and
and kind of going through it I got a
call from a friend kind of checking in
on me and I started complaining right
about how difficult this was and he was
like look dude you're in such an awesome
situation I think you should like really
look at how blessed you are that you
don't have to find a job you've done
this right like I hope I'm in that
position when I'm when I go through the
end of my career right and it was that
conversation that really I think hit me
and put me in a position of wanting to
better my friends who are still skating
and surfing and snowboarding and really
start creating a system that could help
them get through and I chose to do the
same thing I did which was invest in the
commercial real estate so we started a
real estate fund at the beginning of
this year we have two properties in it
we have about 25 investors and it's been
it's been a really good experience to be
able to like make an impact for so many
people that I really care about and if
people want to get involved is it
accredited only or have you opened up so
at the moment it's credited only we're
working at at creating a secondary fund
or transferring this into one that it's
a reggae plus offering we're
unaccredited you can invest it's very
it's expensive and but the SEC makes it
very difficult to to do but we are
looking at that but at the moment it is
for accredited got it and for people to
follow along your journey is Instagram
that the best home my name is Mikey
Taylor on Instagram it's pretty much the
same across the board in all platforms
and then our real estate company is
kommune Capital that's our Instagram or
our websites kommune capital comm
awesome and and then since we're tight
on time the final message
there's entrepreneurs watching they need
more belief in themselves they're
overthinking things they're not doing
the things they want to be doing what's
Mikey Taylor's final piece of advice as
much as I try to plan or prepare for
something once I actually step in doing
it I'm hit with a whole different set of
problems and there's always a problem
and there's always a solution regardless
if everything's going good or bad so
just know that like have confidence in
yourself that you're gonna have problems
it's normal to have problems you're
gonna solve them and keep going and it
really to me comes down to resilience
because this is not easy and a lot of
times you feel like giving up and to me
the ones who succeed are the ones that
don't and keep pushing through and are
able to withstand I think the pressures
of just get something being hard I love
it Mikey Taylor ladies and gentlemen
dude thank you for making the time thank
you for reaching out it's been a blast
and I'm pumped to see where you go with
this new journey and thanks so much I
appreciate talking to you my man all
right take care guys thank you for
watching also if you want to know what I
think and what other successful
entrepreneurs think about building
confidence check out my new 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next two hundred fifty four days for
free I will send you a 30-second to five
minute video in the morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on Europe
it's suppose to mean if you want to
learn from another professional
skateboarder check out the top 10 I did
on Tony Hawk the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
there are people with incredible talent
and no motivation and then there are
other people that are willing to work
their ass off